hey guys merry here with gamespot
presenting the mix at GDC 2016 I am here
with Jarrett and you are here from the
good game Curt the good mood creators
and you're showing Mecca zoo which is a
really visually stunning game like it's
filled with really bright colors and
you're basically just kind of
streamlining through this sweet game and
I want to get right into it just because
it's such a really interesting game
visually but we there's multiple modes
but we're gonna start with single player
mode right sounds good okay let's do it
now tell me but you kind of looks like
you guys were really motivated to have
just streamlined fluid gameplay that was
kind of like something that was a
primary focus for that yeah it's
definitely a flowy experience simple
pick up and play kind of easy to learn
hard to master kind of deal to promotes
right you have main modes you uh you
unlock animals as you go at the end of
each world you fight a big kind of bad
boss version of that next animal you're
about to unlock in a megaman style now
we're starting out with two we got an
army luxuries like a ball for many like
roll just kind of uh yeah just here
quick-like roll around in a ball and
then his action just like dashes then
you can kind of like hold in these
little posts and every animal can
interact these posts in a different ways
turning to the frog and out okay so you
just look at my target in the front
fraud yeah it's like a nice little
tongue lipstick now hey you can hurt
enemies with that as well yeah but then
you can also use it to you can swing on
things the area right so I can hold on
to this crap enemy right right you want
to take him out what are you collecting
from them there's called Mecca balls or
kind of our coins and they give you a
shield if you collect enough of them so
you can take one hit and then there's
also metals for and diamonds we're
collecting enough Mecca balls but yeah
so you unlock each animal at the end of
each world
the only buttons are just action and
transform and movement obviously so it's
a really simple control scheme and now
these self is moving around a lot yeah
so we have 3d environments but it's just
2d gameplay so we kind of just wind a
spline through the 3d environments and
you just play it like a 2d platformer
and our camera kind of follows you
through as you kind of bend on the the
spline as you can see there so yeah I
mean it's made in its main immunity okay
yeah so which is great for indie
developers you know and getting better
all the time luckily for us we've been
working on this for a while and unity
has gone through a lot of iteration
since we started so how large is your
team uh we have about 15 people now 15
yeah so yeah um simple you know troopers
don't have to be working on your
lighting because it's like really good
yeah we have a good art team that's
definitely probably more artists than
any other kind of department and yeah we
have five different five different main
worlds and then each of those worlds as
a bunch of different levels and all of
them have each level has a different
kind of lighting scheme different time
of day and a different feel to it so
there's a lot of visual variety and
yeah and when you say easy to pick up
and difficult to master and what level
of difficulty we're at right now because
already like this is actually pretty
difficult to reverse I mean you guys
need to play this game all the time
right you should be able to kind of
seamlessly flow through it but it seems
like this is something that actually
will take some effort for a like a
regular player yeah well this is about
the fourth level of the game so like
from level one you only have the
armadillo then you fight the frog boss
unlock the frog and then the first level
after each boss is just with the single
animal so you don't have to worry about
switching between animals and you can
kind of get used to the feel of it and
right are there definite animals that
are better for particular situations
that you'd want to switch to yeah well i
mean first of all you only have two
animals available at any given time you
didn't want to bog anything down it's
like inventory management or like a
different button for each animal or
anything like that so yeah they're all
just they have unique like there's a
wallaby that's just like basically a
bouncing ball it's just never stops
bouncing and then his action just makes
them bounce higher Panda that's just
kind of our big look power character
that uh you know can climb walls and
traverse ceilings and we but stomp
totally bad Nikolic and then fly around
so what inspires different animals um I
think we started with kind of mechanics
first we'd like to come we wanted good
combinations like things that would
combine well in different ways you can
start again yeah that like the full demo
right now yeah we just have a one-level
demo right well I mean you also have
co-op or multi p yeah we do co-op so
actually you wanna try that's a basher
let's try it alright hopefully this
works sweet an extra game
had here yeah should work so it's kind
of a high of mine kind of thing it's
offline only for multiplayer and
basically one player has just the switch
button and one player has the action and
movement and when the person is the
switch button switches so right now I
have action and movement so if you press
switch which is X then you get control
and I can steal it back at any time so
we have to kind of work together right
so you so it's kind of yeah like hive
why only doing the switching you're
doing the switching only when I have
control so now if you switch then you
have control now and yeah so then like
when we get to a part where I want to
grab onto that right so yeah it's a it's
just a simple kind of like splitting the
controls off into and that's a nice way
to play the game again but we have a
completely different experience right i
mean there's a lot of communication
involved and especially when you get to
the later levels you have to an end kind
of there's more specific oh yeah
actually yeah you're good after yeah
yeah so you get two parts where you're
like okay you need to be the armadillo
here you see the curbs and
there you go then Isis to throw out the
grab yeah so it's kind of it's just the
fun kind of extra you know get into each
other's minds and there you see you want
to be the dillo there oh right yeah
actually gonna look at the terrain and I
make that choice for you right questions
yeah so all you can do is switch in and
then all i can do is switch in after
after you switch so yeah you got some
funky beat playing in the background to
come from we have an in-house composer
sound designer MJ Quigley is just like
incredible and made a different track
for every level pretty much so it's very
eclectic kind of a lot of different
genres and yeah it's a nice soundtrack
so I like listening to just wanna say
change her environment or yeah so I mean
there's a separate track for each world
but also kind of as you get two
different checkpoints at transitions
into different parts of the song so yeah
it's kind of a little of both
just like a nice fun light-hearted game
that's like enjoyable for people to kind
of pick up and it right yeah I mean it's
it's supposed to be flowy and any any
kind of like puzzle moments that there
are supposed to be solved quickly and
without too much like frustration or
anything but it definitely you know you
get to point yeah you're gonna want to
take you oh add oh we have to get all
the way up there yeah but here if you go
up there again feel a dash hold it and
release yeah yeah and then I switch hard
to get there with
so it's kind of like generally we expect
people to like play a single player and
then after they played the level single
player try it and go off and and then
they can kind of you know hivemind with
each other and how long do you think
like the full game would take um I don't
know maybe like seven hours this total
stab in the dark depends how good you
are I suppose I shouldn't have taken
control right thinners um I mean
obviously there's co-op mode and there's
medals you can collect and like secret
skins you can unlock and stuff like that
so there's a pretty good amount of
replayability mm-hmm take it switch oh
right balls come in like those little
things that we're collecting is that
just four points and score um it's for
well you get diamonds if you collect
enough of them which allows you to
unlock stuff in the shop like the skins
and BGM and stuff and then also you get
a shield after you collect a certain
amount which just allows you to take an
extra hit actually in this build the
effect is not in there
I can't get it okay yeah if you're gonna
have to switch oh how do I get up there
though there's nothing to on your way up
if u dash while you're headed up words
they yeah so there's a lot of nuance to
the controls and that's why I say it
easy to pick up and play but then more
difficult to master it see ya when can
we expect to see this jack we're looking
at August Volga as well and yeah so
we're trying to beat that pretty much
like on the tailins and yeah I mean we
still a lot of work to do but you know
we've been working for a long time and
it's kind of down to polish and working
out bugs and things like that and this
is coming out on everything almost it'll
be on ps4 xbox one pc to start and we
hope to get a wii u version out pretty
quickly and i'm gonna take it from there
so do you have a price in mind hmm we're
still working on it that was meh kazoo
you guys can see that coming up in
august pretty much everything on
consoles and on computer so be sure to
keep looking for that
you